on July 4th 1776 the delegates to the
Second Continental Congress approved the
Declaration of Independence and we know
parts of it very well
for example we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal the Declaration of Independence
was really the point of no return for
the young United States of America
making an appeal to the rest of the
world to say that their time as a colony
of the United Kingdom had ended now the
principle author of the Declaration of
Independence was this man here Thomas
Jefferson I tried to find a picture of
him as a young man in fact at the time
he was about 10 years younger than you
even see him here he was 33
so where did young Thomas Jefferson get
all of the ideas that he expressed in
the Declaration of Independence and what
happened to those ideas once he put them
down on paper in this video I'd like to
explore some of the origins and effects
of the Declaration of Independence now
we often think that the Revolutionary
War started with the Declaration of
Independence we think of 1776 as being
this opening moment of the Revolution in
fact parts of the Revolutionary War had
been going on for some time it was in
1765 more than a decade earlier that
some of the first unrest over taxation
specifically the Stamp Act had begun in
1773 the famous Boston Tea Party when a
group of colonists dumped over 300
crates of tea into Boston Harbor had
happened and in 1775 over a year before
the Declaration of Independence the
first shots of the Revolutionary War had
taken place outside Boston at the towns
of Lexington
and Concord so by the time the delegates
had met in Philadelphia the
Revolutionary War had been a shooting
war for more than a year so why was it
that in July of 1776 the delegates
finally made the Declaration of
Independence well the primary reason
that they did it at this time was
because they wanted help and they were
particularly eager to get the assistance
of the nation of France which had been a
longtime enemy of the United Kingdom and
the delegates really knew that the new
United States of America would have no
hope of winning a war against a massive
imperial power like Great Britain
without the help of another world power
such as France so in a way what
Jefferson was doing in the Declaration
of Independence wasn't so much declaring
but rather explaining why the states
were declaring themselves independent
with the hope that they could get the
sympathy and the help of the
international community so let's read
some of the Declaration of Independence
and I know that this is a gigantic block
of text here but bear with me we'll go
through it fairly quickly the unanimous
declaration of the thirteen United
States of America and you'll notice here
that he specifically points out that
there are 13 United States this is
important because it gives you a sense
that they aren't really thinking of the
individual former colonies now States as
one larger country but rather as a
collection of states a confederation
of Allied states instead of a single
nation when in the course of human
events it becomes necessary for one
people to dissolve the political bands
which have connected them with another
and to assume among the powers of the
earth the separate and equal station to
which the laws of nature and of nature's
God entitle them a decent respect
to the opinions of mankind requires that
they should declare the causes which
impel them to the separation so here's
this explanation part saying we feel it
necessary to explain why we want to
separate from Great Britain we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal that they are
endowed by their creator with certain
unalienable rights that among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness that to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
deriving their just powers from the
consent of the governed that whenever
any form of government becomes
destructive of these ends it is the
right of the people to alter or to
abolish it and to institute new
government laying its foundation on such
principles and organizing its powers in
such form as to them shall seem most
likely to effect their safety and
happiness so I think this might be the
most important passage of the
Declaration of Independence and let me
tell you why in this paragraph you can
really see the influence of the
Enlightenment on Jefferson's thought now
the Enlightenment was a period in the
1600s and 1700s when people began to
explore scientific observation and
reason they became more interested in
observing the world around them and
trying to make reasoned arguments from
what they saw as compared to accepting
the religious explanations for how the
world worked and during the
Enlightenment many philosophers began to
rethink government as well of
questioning whether the governmental
system in Europe and other places was
the right system there was one
philosopher in particular who really
captured Jefferson's imagination and his
name was John Locke
so John Locke was
an English philosopher who had lived in
the 1600s and he wrote a book that had
really influenced Jefferson and many
thinkers in this time period called two
treatises on government and there are
two really important points in Locke's
work one was the idea of natural rights
and what Locke meant by natural rights
our rights that were endowed by nature
that all people were born with now if
you think about Europe in this time
period there was a sense that some
people were born with more rights than
others in fact there was the idea of the
Divine Right of Kings that the king or
monarch of any sort had been born the
king because God wanted that person to
rule well Locke rejects that he says
when people are born they're all born
the same and they all have rights that
can to be given away that are
unalienable and those are life liberty
and property sounds pretty familiar
doesn't it the other important idea that
Locke had it's the idea of the social
contract the idea of the social contract
was that government came from the people
that society members got together and
agreed on what the forms of government
should be so that the only just
government was one that took into
account the opinions of the people who
live within it you see that here two
governments are instituted among men
deriving their just powers from the
consent of the governed and there's a
third
that luck suggests that Jefferson also
gets at which is that when governments
become tyrannical when they do not abide
by the social contract it is the right
of the people to rebel alright back to
the Declaration so most of the rest of
the Declaration is just a list of
grievances of what the king has done to
the colonies that has made them very
angry and this is an extremely abridged
list of them I highly recommend you read
the entire declaration because I think
it gives you a really good sense of what
the colonists were thinking at this time
period but here are some of the
highlights Jefferson says that the king
has kept among us in times of peace
standing armies without the consent of
our legislatures so those are the
British regulars who've been stationed
in North America for a long time for
cutting off our trade with all parts of
the world the navigation acts that said
that the colonies could only trade with
Great Britain for imposing taxes on us
without our consent
the idea of taxation without
representation which really motivated
the colonists to rebel and so forth and
so on now it's worth noting that the
Declaration of Independence as an
explanation hoping to get France on the
side of the new United States worked
very well the United States allied with
France which led them to win the
Revolutionary War in 1783 but as we
close it's worth pondering what it was
that Thomas Jefferson really meant by
the phrase all men are created equal the
Revolutionary War didn't abolish slavery
in the United
States in fact Jefferson himself owns
over a hundred enslaved people of
African descent so when Jefferson said
all men are created equal was he
thinking only of all white men was he
thinking only of elite white men after
all after the Revolution only a handful
of propertied elite men could vote but
then there's this larger idea here he's
saying that your ordinary man wasn't
born any different than someone who was
born a king so why should someone who
was born black be different than someone
who was born white it's hard to imagine
how Jefferson separated those things in
his mind certainly others at the time
period realized that there was an
inherent contradiction between slavery
and also between the rights of women and
the idea that all men are created equal
over time the rhetoric of the
Declaration of Independence would go on
to spur many different movements for
independence and civil rights the most
notable of which being the French
Revolution which took much of its
rhetoric from the American Revolution
and later in 1848 the first women's
rights movement would gather at Seneca
Falls New York and release what they
called the declaration of sentiments
which began all men and women are
created equal so Jefferson's ideas here
are both deeply radical insisting that
ordinary people are just as good as
Kings and even more entitled to decide
their own form of government but that
revolution only went so far it didn't
change much about the status of everyday
citizens in the United States but it put
forward an ideal which we've been
working toward ever since